als sie gestorben ist haben wir
plötzlich erfahren dass sie ihr gesamtes
Vermögen einem Arzt vermacht hat in
einem Münchner Klinikum war Tante
Elfriede ein Hirntumor entfernt worden
sie bankte um ihr Leben war
orientierungslos fühlte sich einsam nach
dem Tod des Mannes da lernte sie in der
Klinik einen Neurologen kennen über den
40 Jahre jüngeren Arzt schrieb sie in
ihrem
Testament der mir in der für mich so
schweren Zeit sehr geholfen hat
diese arztpatientin Beziehung war ihr
stehs suspekt eine gute Bekannte der
Erbtante sie möchte anonym
bleiben das war so eine Abhängigkeit die
da entstanden war seelisch ja ich denke
schon sie war stolz darauf dass er ihr
als Arzt dass er ihr
zuhörte das ist ja ein beträchtliches
Vermögen war das
angemessen nein nein nein ja er hat sich
ja gar nicht viel um sie gekümmert das
heißt er ist mit ihr Essen gegangen er
hat sich beschenken lassen Familie herfs
und die Schwester der Verstorbenen legen
Widerspruch ein im Nachlassverfahren vor
dem bayerischen Amtsgericht
Ebersberg Anna zink ist Zeugin die
langjährige Freundin der arblasserin
schildert vor Gericht wie sich der Arzt
das Vertrauen der alten Dame angeblich
erschlichen habe mit dem Versprechen
dass sie nie in ein Heim müsse mehrere
Zeuginnen behaupten
er sie dann aber doch abgeschoben habe
in ein Heim weit weg von ihrem
Freundeskreis das war sein alterheim er
ausgesucht hat er wollte dass sie nicht
mehr zum stammdisch geht weil er
behauptet hat der stammdisch würde sie
negativ
beeinflussen der Arzt der hier mit
seinem Anwalt am Gericht ankommt
widerspricht das Heim sei nach Absprache
mit der Erblasserin und dem Sozialdienst
des Krankenhauses gewählt
worden dass er das Alleinerbe bekommen
war das verhältnismäßig nee was hat er
denn gemacht dass er sie besucht hat und
dann hat s bezahlt fürs besuchen was
heißt das ja dass dass sie immer dass er
dass sie immer ihn und der Familie Geld
in die Hand gedrückt hat wenn er sie
endlich mal wieder besucht
hat das hat ja selber erzählt wie viel
Geld das möchte jetzt nicht sag größere
Summen ja größere Summen der Arzt
bestreitet jemals Geschenke oder Geld
genommen zu haben er habe erst nach dem
Tod der früheren Patientin von seinem
Erbe erfahren daran zweifeln die
Freundinnen der Verstorbenen denn es gab
dieses notarielle Testament Z Gunsten
des Arztes und wie das zustande kam soll
die Erblasserin am Stammtisch erzählt
haben ja sicher hat er das aus wer würde
sonst ein Notar bringen und sagen jetzt
machen wir notariellen Vertrag damit ich
sicher auf der sichersten Seite bin wir
konfrontieren den Arzt noch Verdach nur
sein Anwalt
reagiert haben sie ke skel
Million sie sie sollen ein Versprechen
abgegeben haben der alten Dame dass sie
niemals in ein Hein
kommt im Landeskriminalamt Berlin ist
Hauptkommissarin Annette mau
schwerpunktermittlerin für Fälle von
Ausbeutung älterer Menschen sie
Gesetzeslücken
anerei ist nicht strafbewährt der
Gesetzgeber hat dort keine Regelung
geschaffen und alles was nicht verboten
ist ist erlaubt das heißt es ist ein
gewisses Ohnmachtsgefühl auch für Sie
als
Ermittlerin ja das kann ich nur so
stehen lassen warum wir können keinen
schützen ein erbverbot für Ärzte und
Pflegepersonal ist natürlich immer
sinnvoll denn mit einem generellen
erbverbot für Personal im
Gesundheitswesen würde Missbrauch
erschwert nur selten kommt es zu
Verurteilungen wie in einem besonders
perfiden Fall am Amtsgericht München im
Mai das Urteil ist noch nicht
rechtskräftig betrügerischer Arzt muss
ins Gefängnis gut dre Jahre Haft für
einen Hausarzt der seine Patienten um
fastst eine halbe Million erleichtert
haben soll das Gericht hat ferner
hervorgehoben dass der Angeklagte gerade
in seiner Funktion als Arzt dieses
Vertrauensverhältnis aufgebaut hat und
hat als besonders gravierend noch
herausgearbeitet dass der Angeklagte im
Rahmen seiner Betrügereien auch
Erkenntnisse die er aus dem
patientenverhältnis gewonnen hatte für
seine Taten ausgenutzt hat schleicherei
im Gesundheitswesen Einfallstor für
einen solch schweren Vertrauensbruch
sind laut Experten vor allem
vorsorgeevollmachten per Unterschrift
erteilen Patienten Ihrem Arzt Pfleger
oder Therapeuten damit weitreichende
Vollmachten für Rechtsgeschäfte und für
den Zugriff auf Ihr Vermögen auch hier
müsste der Gesetzgeber dringend
nachbessern eine ordentliche
vorsorgevollmachtsregelung die klare
rechtliche Bestimmung hat die kann man
finden wir zumindest an bestimmte Hürden
setzen geschäftsfähigkeitsnachweis zu
erbringen dass man es eben
zwangsregistrieren muss dass eine
bestimmte Form hat genau das hat die
ampelregierung im Koalitionsvertrag auch
versprochen wir werden ältere Menschen
vor Diskriminierung und vor finanzieller
Ausbeutung insbesondere durch
Vorsorgevollmachten
schützen wir fragen nach bei
Bundesjustizminister Marco Buschmann
kein Interview schriftlich heißt es
Zitat wer ältere Menschen durch dazu
bringt über ihr Vermögen zu verfügen
macht sich bereits nach geltendem Recht
wegen Betrugs strafbar das rechtliche
Instrumentarium ist somit ausreichend
Versprechen gebrochen meint dazu der
bayerische Justizminister Georg
Eisenreich er fordert schon lange
besseren Schutz für
Senioren ich sehe sowohl im Zivilrecht
als auch im strafrechtgesetzlichen
Handlungsbedarf wir haben auch
entsprechende Vorschläge gemacht aus
meiner Sicht sind ältere Menschen
besonders schutzwürdig und deswegen
verstehe ich diese Ablehnung des
bundesjustizministers nicht der
Münchener erbrechtsspezialist Wolfgang
Bö ist Anwalt der Familie herfs er
fordert generell gesetzliche
Nachbesserungen für die Beurteilung von
testier Unfähigkeit also wenn die
Fähigkeit eingeschränkt ist den eigenen
Willen unbeeinflusst zu
formulieren in Deutschland ist es so
dass man nur bei einer psychiatrischen
Grunderkrankung zu einer Unwirksamkeit
kommen kann wie aber eine viel Zahl von
Fällen kennen in denen ein
Abhängigkeitsverhältnis besteht und es
natürlich nicht gewährleistet ist dass
da noch eine freie Willensbildung
stattfinden kann und gerade in diesen
abhängigkeitsfällen mit körperlichen
Grunderkrankungen müsste man aus meiner
Sicht beim Gesetzgeber nachrüsten an
eine Testierunfähigkeit des verstorbenen
Vaters glauben auch Sohn Thomas Meder
und Schwiegertochter Anke der Vater
hatte selbst ein Vermögen geerbt seinen
Kindern schon zu Lebzeiten Häuser
vermacht
nach dem Tod der Ehefrau aber kam es zum
Bruch mit den Kindern mein Vater war ja
nur vier Jahre in der Schule und konnte
kaum lesen und schreiben er hatte schon
vier
Schlaganfälle und nach dem Unfalltod
meiner Mutter hat sie sich sein ganzer
Zustand noch
verschlechtert diese Notlage habe sich
eine Therapeutin des Vaters angeblich zu
Nutze gemacht Vertrauen erschlichen und
sich beim Notar für das resterbe im Wert
von rund 90.000 € einsetzen lassen die
Kinder erfuhren von dieser Erbeinsetzung
erst nach dem Tod des Vaters jetzt
klagen sie das war ein Jahr vor seinem
Tod hat er sich mit der Familie wieder
ausgesöhnt und wollte allerdings von der
Logopädie nichts mehr wissen wie erklärt
die Therapeutin dann ihren Anspruch auf
das Erbe wir treffen Sie mit Ihrem
Anwalt vor dem Gerichtsgebäude wollen
uns erklären warum sie hier Patienten
beerben wollen finden sie das nicht
unanständig was sagen sie dazu dass der
erer von ihen distanziert hat ja wollen
Erben aber nicht
antworten schriftlich teilt uns der
Anwalt der Therapeutin mit der ablasser
habe sich zu Lebzeiten einer
fachärztlichen Untersuchung unterzogen
danach sein Zitat keinerlei
Anhaltspunkte festgestellt worden die
einer testamentserstellung
entgegenstehen das hätten zwei
gerichtlich bestellte Gutachter
bestätigt doch das Oberlandesgericht
Karlsruhe rügt inzwischen dass die
Testierfähigkeit des erblas bisher nicht
ausreichend ermittelt wurde nun wieder
Zuversicht bei den
Hinterbliebenen nach 7 Jahren hat das
Gericht endlich
den Hausarzt meines Vaters und auch uns
angehört und wir hoffen dass es jetzt
endlich zur Wahrheitsfindung beiträgt
einen besseren Schutz vor Erbschleichern
in Deutschland fordert auch die Juristin
Claudia mler Mitglied im
Menschenrechtsrat der
UN in den USA ist die Lage derzeit so
dass es das sogenannte den sogenannten
Rechtsbegriff undue influence gibt das
ist diese unangemessene Beeinflussung
wenn beispielsweise ein pflegerisches
Personal oder ein Arzt oder ein Betreuer
dort das Vertrauen der Person
erschleicht genau mit dem Sinn und Zweck
sich die Erbschaft zu sichern dann kann
das Geschäft rückabgewickelt werden dies
ist in Deutschland mit der derzeitigen
vollmachtlage nicht möglich
her und Ehemann wollen weiterkämpfen für
ihre private behindinderten WG das
Millionenerbe von Tante elfride wollen
Sie dem Arzt nicht freiwillig
überlassen ich finde es ungeheuerlich wo
dieser Mann zufähig ist er hat die
Hilflosigkeit meiner Tante ausgenutzt
und er hatte alle Möglichkeiten als Arzt
und wusste genau wie er sie manipulieren
kte die Vorwürfe gegen den Arzt sind
bisher nicht bewiesen das Gericht muss
noch entscheiden wird die nichtichte
Erben können oder darf der Arzt das
Millionenvermögen als Alleinerbe
antreten